foreign
[Music]
good trick is to pump to the tune of
Staying Alive by the Bee Gees do you
know that song yes yes I do I love that
song
first I was afraid I was petrified no
it's
staying alive you were in the parking
lot earlier that's how I know you
okay
[Music]
Staying Alive
it's Brittany I wish I could throw
this in the Box
why don't you just buy the whole song
why don't I have to buy it
I just want to taste it
swap
I just want a little taste of it
thank you
[Music]
you got created you jump in front of
them make it so hard to love you
sometimes
I said I didn't want to be on the
internet yeah okay dancing it is a
primal art form used in ancient times to
express yourself with the body
and communicate
okay uh you know what maybe I'll I'll
finish explaining the rule let's let me
explain it first and then
[Music]
yeah so we'll get right you know what
I'll be right
Stanley you're taking over for me buddy
okay
um
[Music]
television North Korea South Korea
Marilyn Monroe Ryan started the fire
whatever we deny we
[Music]
belong
we belong We Belong Together
[Music]
I have no gift to bring
that's fit to give our king
[Music]
um
for me the day begin
You Are The Sunshine that lights my
heart with it sorry I annoyed you with
my friendship
excuse me
and I'm also sorry that a lot of people
here
for some reason think it's funny to
steal someone's personal property and
hide it from them
here's a little news flash it's not
funny
in fact it's pretty freaking unfunny
[Music]
all right
how will I remember the look that was in
his eyes stealing kisses from me on the
slide taking time to make time
telling me that he's all mine
learning from each other's knowing
looking to see how much we've got at the
old okay yeah this is a duet so
come up in there sing this one
need somebody else takers please
give me when I met you there was peace
unknown Kelly I try to get you where to
find tooth come out with soft inside
there's something going on
this part goes the uh
girl
something to me that I can't explain
hold me closer and I feel now please
Where Are You Dean trophy Suite 100 and
blinds and rugs sweet 202. here it is
gonna sing that part I know now you
don't have to yeah except it was going
to resolve the melody so now my head
hurts feels like I held in a sneeze
I hate this feeling
sweet photo one
you have any music
yeah I should have said so
give me the beat boys and free my soul I
wanna get lost in your rock and roll and
drift away
[Music]
I was thinking more like a CD or a CD
you
[Music]
ought to know
no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no that's really
pretty song
[Music]
that's when you hear me what's getting
you down all right
[Music]
I suppose
take me home to the place sorry I like
that song you're good you're good thank
you that was great but it's just sort of
it's still a little choppy like but
don't worry it's hard it took me a while
too it's like okay
[Music]
wow
what oh my God you heard that I'm so
embarrassed I'm so like Rusty dude
you're really coming along it's really
technically proficient but you know
there's really no harder soul in it
really
[Music]
hey you want to sing it with me
Almost Heaven West Virginia
Blue Ridge Mountains
[Music]
I belong to West Virginia
Mountain Mama
take me home
Country Roads
[Music]
you have to stop